il aime buzzati michel suau gpo journey
bonsoir bonsoir
alors ça ça crée quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de réactions cette proposition
de taxe qui viserait en fait qui vise
donc koné 0 détails sur le camp comme un
conte bien et qui viserait les non
vaccinés au québec je vous montrais en
début d'émission bon les jeunes
canadiens qui ont fait la une avec ça
mais le guardian le fun article cnn le
monde bbc news qui a relayé parce que
chacun cherche
beaucoup dans deux pays cherchent des
manières originales et ce que celle là
en est une autre je veux vous entendre
là dessus avant d'entendre monsieur
trudeau tour de table d'abord 24 heures
plus tard qu'est ce que comment vous
voyez la shoah aux hellènes mais moi ce
qui me fait ça quoi j'arrive c'est on
parle beaucoup de la vaccination
obligatoire on commence à dire qu'on
devrait instaurer une vaccination
obligatoire mais voilà le un des visages
de la vaccination obligatoire voilà ce à
quoi ça peut ressembler parce que
entendons-nous même si la loi québécoise
sur la santé publique le permet
théoriquement d'envoyer quelqu'un dans
une pièce pour le forcer à lui insérer
une aiguille de force dans le bras même
si c'est potentiel c'est possiblement
permis dans les faits personne ne songe
à ça alors quand on parle de vaccination
obligatoire c'est faites vous vacciner
sinon il y aura une conséquence et voilà
on a choisi pour la conséquences
pécuniaires
je pense que je pense que les gens sont
proches de la porte monnaie et que ça
peut effectivement avoir un effet autres
c'est ce que monsieur dubé midi
aujourd'hui en disant qu'il ya une
augmentation encore plus grande le des
prises de rendez vous pour une première
dose de vaccin mais je vais vous poser
une question mais je vais continuer mon
tour de tam et je vous dis tout de suite
je vous reposer la question après mais
pourquoi ne pas alors dire que la
vaccination est obligatoire et seront
pas vaccinés bien sûr qu'on rentre un
peu une aiguille de force mais auront
des amendes il se serait un peu le même
résultat mais michel d'abord je continue
tour de table l'impression générale 24
heures après
légèrement pire que celle que j'ai eue
hier
c'est pas que c'est pas quelque chose
qui va marcher très bien ça va être très
compliqué expo / que ça s est beaucoup
de gens à se faire vacciner à la fin je
pense pas que la vaccination obligatoire
surveille aaron ce ne soit une meilleure
solution non plus mais on a vu la
réaction vous l'avez montré tout à
l'heure des trois pôles ministre
conservateur de l'alberta saskatchewan
moi je toucherai pas valérie ne bouge
jeu de monsieur le boucher j'y réfléchis
la pole
24 heures plus tard en fait c'est on
prédire aussi une semaine et demie plus
tard parce que monsieur legault avait
télégraphié ses intentions à la fin
décembre mais on a laissé sa flotté dans
l'air puis on est revenu à la chance
puis j'imagine que le gouvernement est
content qu'on parle de ça et non du
départ de ratio à rôdeur mais je dirais
que depuis environ une ou deux semaines
se contentant surtout c'est la colle
leur majorité contre les non vaccinés
mais là au fur et à mesure qu'on
réfléchisse plus concrètement à une
contribution santé ben on réalise que
c'est plus compliqué en pratique est
aussi que ça pose plusieurs problèmes de
principe la prétention de base du
gouvernement se dire que ça va augmenter
le taux de vaccination sans doute que ça
pourrait convaincre certaines personnes
se disent très attention avant de faire
un lien de cause à effet avec la ligue
nouvelles personnes sont arrivées à
vacciner plus que six à cause de la
gravité de la pandémie oui c'est à cause
de l'élargissement à venir du pass
parents vaccinale mais même si ça a une
utilité pour certaines personnes on
réalise que ça pourrait avoir un effet
de ressac auprès d'autres personnes
récalcitrantes qui pourraient se braquer
voir se radicaliser et enfin qu'il ya
des gens vulnérables
ah si on contribution si on se demande
comment ça fonctionnerait ce que vous
allez voir un sans abri puis lui donner
un ticket parce qu'il
allait chercher ces gens là donc j'ai
vraiment plusieurs problèmes auxquels il
faudrait d'urgence réfléchir avant
d'aller de l'avant avec ça bon ça c'est
une autre bonne question que je vous
pose est comment protéger les plus
vulnérables comment faire et comment je
vais faire entendre monsieur trudeau
évidemment il s'attendait à se faire
poser la question très prudent
maintenant il veut pas fermer la porte
parce que lui ça va ça va dans le même
sens son discours de politiquement de
tout faire pour faire vacciner les gens
ont les coudes pour rien nous avions
pris des mesures très fortes pour
encourager les gens de se faire vacciner
des provinces ont pris des mesures des
très fortes déjà alors il n'y a pas une
opposition de la part du gouvernement à
ce qu'on prenne des mesures fortes
mais nous allons toujours cherché à ce
que ces mesures soient efficaces soient
dans le respect des principes et des
valeurs et puisse nous faire avancer
c'est pour ça que les détails sont sciés
portons
alors il se mouille pas trop en
attendant les détails ouais c'est ça
mais il pas tellement un choix d'être
prudent parce que d'abord c'est lui
monsieur trudeau en campagne électorale
l'automne dernier qui a beaucoup
contribué à la politisation de la
vaccination en voulant coincer son
adversaire et renault tous les
d'ailleurs il ne rate toujours il ne
rate jamais une occasion de remettre sur
la table de d'attaqué est un hôte où le
chef conservateur alors il a contribué à
instaurer un climat où on traite les non
vaccinés comme des moins que rien c est
pire boucs émissaires alors je les sers
peu le résultat tout ça mais il est
prudent parce qu'on a quelque part il
fait un peu la même chose lui en tant
que employeurs fédéral il a instauré la
vaccination obligatoire des
fonctionnaires fédéraux et quand on y
pense qu'elle est la conséquence si vous
ne vous faites pas vacciner en tant que
fonctionnaire et ben vous êtes suspendu
sans solde soit ça veut dire un salaire
de 40 50 70 mille dollars que vous
connaissez bien plus que l'amendé de
plus 200 dollars à laquelle songe
monsieur legault alors il serait bien
malvenu d'être content alors qu'il fait
exactement la même chose aux épaules
mais j'ai une grande différence avec le
passeport vaccinale je trouve que
l'élargissement ne se passe par
vaccinale se défend beaucoup mieux parce
qu'on comprend la logique de santé
publique derrière ceux ci les gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés n'ont pas accès à
certains lieux ben on réduit la
possibilité de contact et donc de
contamination et de pression sur le
système hospitalier
donc qu'il ya une logique claire
présence préventive de santé publique
alors que si on lui avec une
contribution santé on arrive après le
coup on présume que les gens vont
répondre à des pénalités puis il prend
le manque est guère après le pire de la
cinquième vague donc toutes sortes de
problèmes pratiques qui se pose à sa
pile on n'a même pas parlé du danger
d'induire dans le système de santé une
logique de contributeurs payeur donc
c'est pour ça que le passeport vaccinale
moi ça me semble beaucoup plus beau
travail à certains commerces à me sens
beaucoup plus cohérent comme mesure de
santé publique alors qu'il y ait de
faire payer les non vaccinés ben c'est
surtout qu'ils ont constaté la majorité
qui est en colère puis on leur dit
justice envie de vous venger mais pour
la façon je trouve la réaction
les fonctionnaires fédéraux ils sont
presque tous en télétravail alors la
logique que dont paul parle c'est
peut-être vrai mais certainement pas
dans la fonction publique c'est et on le
veut on le voit avec mac renvoyeur de le
l'attrait de faire du millage politique
ou si
michel c'est en fera pas sur les
non-vaccinés ans à compter de leur forme
finalement on va les faire payer on va
les emmerder comme à 10 microns il ya un
petit souci hier
il ya beaucoup de sens de la raison pour
laquelle monsieur le groupe sas et
punitifs sais pas pour quelle puce de
gex facebook si nice pau puis il est
vraiment dans une logique de punition
pourquoi monsieur trudeau est aussi plus
d'heures ça c'est une autre histoire pas
sa seule poignée pour intervenir dans ce
dossier
qui ne lui donnent qu'une seule arme
c'est de réduire les transferts aux
provinces vous imaginez-vous
gouvernement fédéral appelé milieu de ne
pas débit réduire les transferts aux
provinces ça n'a pas de sens alors même
si les valeurs canadiennes est on
aujourd'hui aux trois premiers ministres
provinciaux là il à l universalité c'est
sacré à 100 pays même si sa cause un
problème d'universalité ce que monsieur
legault propose et de gratuité aussi il
peut le général ne vaut pas répondre
avec la célèbre qui doit
ce drôle de loi d'ailleurs bon je vous
en parle et c'est la deuxième fois alors
j'ai compris on va les écouter
saskatchewan en ontario en fait dans
l'ordre inverse ontario alberta
saskatchewan je crois on y va
bon y'a des gens santé publique donc il
souhaite que les gens se fassent
vacciner qui ont des gros doutes aussi
un directeur de la santé publique en
gaspésie yves docteur bonnier qu'ils
attention la fin on fait fausse route on
écoute
quand on regarde la proposition qui nous
est faite elle va à l'encontre de
plusieurs de ses valeurs et de ses
principes scientifiques de base dans le
domaine de la santé publique alors ce
n'est pas une solution qu'on peut lancer
comme ça du jour au lendemain on pas ce
que ça exige si on veut la considérer
beaucoup d'examens de début
y at il eu beaucoup d'examens et de
débats paul
non parce qu'on a ça veut dire ça ça a
commencé avec une commande de politique
du premier ministre legault et l'examen
est plus technique puisse faire au
ministère des finances on est en train
de réfléchir entre économistes et
fiscalistes sur la meilleure façon
savoir quelle institution va prélever la
contribution qu'elle sera à hauteur à
thiais le moment est ce qu'on va le
faire est ce qu'il y aura des exemptions
et cette erreur donc on est tous de
tomber dans le coma avant de commencer à
avec la réflexion sur les moyens et puis
c'est pour faire un lien avec les gens
la santé publique qui s'y opposent il
faut aussi comprendre c'est quoi la
proche de santé publique souvent la
grande majorité des gens qui travaillent
en santé publique ce qui les intéresse
ce sont les déterminants sociaux de la
santé donc toutes les conditions de vie
pauvreté problèmes de santé mentale ecce
terra
inégalités de revenus et qui peut mener
à des problèmes de santé donc ce n'est
pas surprenant que les gens la santé
publique soient méfiants de telles
mesures
punitives et aux effets possiblement
régressif il faut comprendre la
sociologie ou si des gens qui ne sont
pas vaccinés a qui sont utiles c'est pas
des gens nécessairement tous qui vont
vacciner qui vont manifester qui ont des
convictions de large est
ok et là je vous demander est-ce que ça
n'aurait pas été plus simple manette
tout à l'heure pour le québec dans le
fond plus frontale plus claire de dire
bon ben on va s'assumer mais plutôt que
de faire part bout alcool machin on va
imposer une vaccination obligatoire pour
tout le monde ce qu'ils feront pas bhl
iran le choix de paul faire meilleur des
âmes
mais c'est un peu ce qu'on fait en fait
oui mais non
mais non mais oui
c'est pas obligatoire plus on ajoute
plein de mails oui bien sûr mais
évidemment on peut pas se prononcer de
manière définitive parce qu'on n'a pas
le détail concret de la mesure qui est
envisagé ce qu'on dit moi québec c'est
que y'a 2 a vu préconisé encore
privilégiée celle évidemment de la
fiscalité donc on ferait sa part le
rapport d'impôt une ligne de plus et là
est ce qu'on la date est ce qu'on le
module c'est selon le revenu ou post
c'est à suivre l'autre avenue ce serait
carrément de prendre nos registres de
haut du régime d'assurance maladie et
voir qui ont pas été vaccinés on envoie
une amende par la poste mais le résultat
est quand même la main mc faites vous
vacciner où il y aura un coût
association comprend personnes beaucoup
parlent des personnes - privilégier les
sans abri beaucoup et les sans papiers
on entendit parler beaucoup de ça ce
qu'à québec on me dise pas oui mais
soyons réalistes ces deux catégories de
gens justement ne remplissent pas de
rapports d'impôts non potable adresse ou
alors que l'adresse connu de l'état et
donc les avenues qu on privilégierait à
québec ne serait pas de nature à
pénaliser ces deux catégories de
personnes pour lesquelles on avait
craqué mais je repose la question je
peux être fatigant mais michel et ça ne
serait pas plus claire
plus clair où il de dire vaccination
obligatoire au québec pour les comme en
italie par an pour les 50 ans et plus et
ceux qui n'y vont pas
s'exposeront s'exposeraient à des
amendes michel
oui mais est-ce que ça va marcher le
problème et ça aussi on peuvent être
décrétés la vaccination universelle je
pose sur moi qui aie ça pour ça des gens
de 50 ans et plus qui sous peine d'une
visite des carabinieri sont d'essence
ont reculé en italie ne faut pas
charrier avec cela un moment donné ce
que ça va donner quelque chose
la ligne dans le rapport de pokhara pour
sabler québécois de le petro dépôt c'est
à moment donné ça votre étude si l'on
peut on peut décréter quelque chose je
ne serai pas en effet pas mon le fait
vraiment pour n'ajoute pas la saq pour
neigeux peine je pense que ça donne rien
c'est ce que j'essaie de vous dire je
pense qu'on contribue de façon
comme le couvre-feu on peut se poser des
questions orales
je pense à ça risque quand même de
donner quelque chose on se demande si ce
le gain qui serait suffisant pour
justifier tout trop de cons se donnerait
mais pour venir vous n'êtes pas le voit
quand même sur le plan des conséquences
entre la vaccination obligatoire puis
une espèce de taxes une contribution
c'est vrai que ça se ressemble mais le
message est la logique est quand même
très différent là on dit au lieu de
faire appel à auchan en tant que cliente
les consommateurs en dix ans avait
répondait à des incitatifs financiers
sinon vous tape sur les doigts le ont
fait davantage avec la vaccination
obligatoire contre est davantage appel
ou un devoir citoyen de protéger les
autres et d'éviter le pire pour notre
système de santé qui approche à certains
endroits d'une nouvelle phase 5 le daily
star on est quand même une différence
dans le messager si ce qui a déjà été
fait rapidement il y en a déjà eu de
vaccination obligatoire au québec puis
en a ailleurs puis en existe pour les
enfants dans des certaines provinces
canadiennes ne s'est pas quelque chose
de complètement
inexistant
dr arruda vous avez dit paul doute à
l'âge conseil du tour de table eddy
mottaz on parle de chats de la taxe pour
les non vaccinés plutôt que du docteur
arruda jeu fort trop de la question 24
heures plus tard à fait là c'est plus
que ça parce qu'on l'ait reçue la veille
et puis et puis il paul vous avez écrit
là-dessus ce matin bris puis j'avais
plus dans votre analyse oui
notes pendant tout le monde est en train
d'essayer de se demander qui sera le
nouveau directeur national permanent je
pense que celui qui est en poste
par intérim mais risquent de le rester
pendant pas mal à tout la crise tout
autre la cinquième banque qui vont
possiblement jusqu'à du gouvernement
actuel et que toutes les belles idées de
réformes pour que monsieur arbres pour
que le successeur de monsieur
santé publique soit plus un sous
ministre adjoint bien il faudrait
rouvrir il faudrait changer la loi c'est
aussi ça n'arrivera pas donc il faudra
s'en remettre
l'attitude du nouveau directeur espérer
que de sa propre initiative il soit plus
transparent on n'est pas allé chercher
un médecin de terrain pour brasser la
cage le site en un gestionnaire de
carrière qui est à la tête de l'inhesj
de l'icône spq qui déjà l'habitude de
travailler avec le gouvernement donc
ceux qui s'attendent à un changement
radical
c'est l'adage pense pas est-ce qu'il a
intérêt à roudet michel et hélène le
fusible qu'on a fait sauter pour rendre
les prochaines semaines plus apaisé
c'est sûr que ça fait partie de la
réflexion du gouvernement sur
son partenaire là il ya beaucoup de gens
qui lui remettait beaucoup sur le dos de
doctor who do beaucoup trop d'ailleurs
l'ail est plus lent alors vous vous
trouvez qu'on a été dur avec lui on est
les commentateurs les chroniqueurs
général où ils étaient ils disaient les
mêmes choses que le docteur house états
unis puis que bien d'autres au début de
sauvegarde n'a pas débuté le judo
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'est trompé
tout le talent il était pas pire que les
autres mais là il des flux au hockey le
paratonnerre des pluies l'ofppt ils sont
des successeurs aux lois est un homme
extrêmement prudent pire on l'a vu hier
la prudence à part vous voulez vous avez
un méchant vous a fait réagir ou pas
rapproché
clarté c'est que c'est l'explication ce
patient ça aurait pu être plus clair
hélène moi j'étais assez d'accord avec
michel je pense qu'on a été un peu dur
avec monsieur arruda et effectivement le
gouvernement perd paratonnerre avec son
départ et je passe sauf que le
gouvernement était si content que ça de
le perdre ici pour ce que moi j'adhère
au travail aurait pu garder
à partir du moment où on commence à
s'interroger sur notre sort c'est un peu
difficile je pense que monsieur roux
doit être difficile les critiques de ses
autres collègues la santé publique mais
est ce parce que moi j'adhère pomme la
thèse de la taxe comme diversion si
cette taxe qui est annoncée voulait
faire diversion c'est surtout je pense
sur le délestage dont on n'a à peu près
pas parlé avec le premier ministre et
qu'elle pourtant une grande crise
le hockey mais on va en parler demain on
va parler des écoles c'est les annonces
pour les écoles et dont on est à peu
près tous convaincus qu'elles qu'elles
vont rouvrir mais si jamais elle devait
pas rouvrir mais l'os libre
paratonnerre d'un coup de tonnerre salut
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit